from the demigod shard bearers that make
up most of the main bosses to the god
queen america to the ever-reaching
urgery worship deities and gods make up
a significant theme of elden rings world
but beyond and above all of these simple
gods and demigods of the lands between
lie the outer gods ominous figures that
we never see in game but whose actions
pull the strings and set the stage for
the world we play in
as these beings are only ever referenced
and not actually seen their entire
existence can be missed by a casual
player and even a lore sleuth may be
left grasping for anything concrete to
say about them so in this video i'll be
explaining what we know about the outer
gods of eldon ring each and every one of
them
briefly stated they are the greater will
the frenzied flame the formless mother
the scarlet right god the god of the
death birds the fel god the god of the
dragons and the moon
i'll have something to say about that
last one
first is the greater will this is the
most well-known obvious and directly
influencing outer god it's even
explicitly mentioned by npcs like enya
the greater will is the entity behind
the elden ring the deification of
america and the message and authority of
the two fingers
any references the greater will quite a
few times in her dialogue and this is
likely why most players will know of it
in interpreting the two fingers she says
that the greater will has not abandoned
the world despite its state of disarray
she says it is pleased when you acquire
two great runes of the elden ring though
the erd tree's rejection of the player
and the subsequent consulting that the
two fingers does with the greater will
may hint at a sinister truth that the
greater will is not communicating with
the two fingers and that it may actually
have abandoned the world
see according to the elden star's
incantation the greater will spawned the
elden ring and the order that came up
around it it sent a golden star burying
a beast into the lands between which
would later become the elden ring the
greater will installed the order that
came to dominate the lands between
indirectly through this order and
directly through its own power the
greater will defeated the dragons
destroyed the giants enslaved the
misbegotten reviled the omen banished
the knocks cursed the eternal cities and
buried the entire clan of merchants
alive
but it did make life pretty good for
everyone else at least at the start of
the order during the time of the urgery
blessings
the greater will seems to have
originally blessed its chosen people or
faction with strength and other sorts of
blessings but it also demanded complete
subjugation and then let the world fall
into disarray
now it seems to have abandoned the lands
between at least in terms of actively
helping out or not
it still holds control over the age as
the age is one defined by the elden ring
and urgery but that may be coming to an
end for it seems that queen merica the
one the greater will made a vessel for
the elden ring had some form of falling
out with this outer god and despite all
those grave crimes i mentioned earlier i
just can't fathom why in spite of being
ordained by the greater will it is
merica who is connected with the black
knife assassins and it is she who
shattered the elden ring there was much
speculation to be had concerning the
greater will enough to fill many
separate videos but now we have somewhat
of a clearer picture of what it is the
main being behind the setup of the world
as we see it but not something so pure
and righteous as its golden light might
suggest when your appointed god turns on
you not to mention a host of others that
we'll talk about soon and most of the
world hates your representative it might
be time to reconsider whether you are
the good party from our eyes as the
tarnished the greater will is the outer
god we know the most about and despite
its appearances it seems to be a dark
and controlling one one that inspires
rebellion from its so-called greater
will even the name implies its design to
override the will and choice of the
people under it the people of the lands
between
whereas the greater will has the two
fingers the frenzied flame has the three
fingers while not called out as
explicitly as the greater will it seems
clear that an outer god of frenzy flame
is represented by the frenzy based three
fingers
fortunately for us there is a little bit
clearer information about the flame
firstly we know that its incantations
produce frenzy turning people mad
in this way it is quite like the
lovecraftian great old ones which seem
to be direct inspiration for this game's
outer gods both lovecraft's monsters and
the frenzied flame are too much for a
human or tarnished mind to comprehend
and we go insane when confronted with
them just like the characters from
lovecraft's stories secondly the frenzy
flame has a dedicated ending and some
dialogue that clearly lays out its
aspirations the lord of frenzy flame
ending shows the world being melted away
into a single being burned by the yellow
chaos flame but before this we can talk
to hayeta to hear her speak for the
three fingers and about the desire of
the frenzied flame speaking to her after
acquiring the mark of the fingers she
says all that there is came from the one
great then came fractures
and births
and souls
but the greater will made a mistake
torment
despair
affliction every sin
every curse
every one born of the mistake
and so
what was borrowed
must be returned
melt it all away with the yellow chaos
flame
until all
is won again
so originally the greater will and the
frenzied flame were one bean the
so-called one great makes sense that
they have the two fingers and the three
fingers as representatives then two plus
three equals five fingers or one whole
hand and the frenzy flame sees all the
pain of the world the curses and sin and
torment as a result of the greater will
introducing divisions and individuality
it wants to melt everything back into
one where there will be no individuals
and no pain basically it's end of
evangelion
so we do learn that the greater will
does have some positives it let there be
individuals life and real thought but
it's also worth noting that the frenzied
flame may have only been able to contest
the greater will due to the greater
will's own wrongdoing remember when i
said the greater will and its order
buried the clan of merchants alive while
the rest of the merchant armor set reads
that after they were buried they chanted
a curse of despair and summoned the
flame a frenzy so even if the aim of the
flame is contestable it might only be
around because of the greater will and
its cruelty
though if we do succumb to
short-sightedness and hatred for the
greater will we are reminded of the
mistaken path of this specific
alternative for if we consider a return
to the lifeless singularity the frenzy
flame wishes melano argues the other
side
saying if you intend to claim the
frenzied flame
i ask that you cease
it is not to be meddled with
it is chaos devouring life and thought
unending
however ruined this world has become
however mired in torment and despair
life endures
births continue
there is beauty in that
is there not
if you would become lord
do not deny this notion
please
leave the frenzied flame alone
now we begin the outer gods confirmed
and potential that we don't know that
much about first is the formless mother
or mother of truth this is a being who
craves wounds and probably blood if i
had to guess and she was served by moog
lord of blood in front of her moog's
accursed blood that is his omen blood
erupted with fire from his sacred spear
we learn more of this connection it
describes itself as an instrument of
communion with an outer god who bestows
power upon accursed blood it concludes
the mother of truth desires a wound if
we look closely at moog's boss fight we
can see that many of his attacks
especially his spear nihil attack
involve creating portals when we read
his spear's skill we learn what he is
doing
raise the sacred spear and pierce the
body of the formless mother so moog is
able to pierce this outer god and create
explosions of blood maybe she offers her
power in return for moog service and
continual creation of more blood
but beyond this we don't know much moog
had his ambitions of creating a dynasty
through mykola but for whatever reason
that didn't work out it probably didn't
help that mikala had an aversion to the
meddling of the outer gods
we don't know what the formless mother
wants other than blood and wounds
formless could mean she has no real body
and mother of truth could denote some
aspect of true insight into the way of
the world but we just don't have
anything else to go off of or draw
conclusions from
another clearly stated but lacking info
outer god is the god of scarlet rot or
simply rot itself the story begins with
the blue dancer charm which states the
dancer in blue represents a fairy who in
legend bestowed a flowing sword upon a
blind swordsman blade in hand the
swordsman sealed away an ancient god a
god that was rot itself the scorpion's
stinger dagger confirms a scarlet rot
bean which is a sealed outer god
maybe it was sealed in a cavern that
later became the lake of rot it lay
sealed but its power still oozes out so
here we have an outer god present in the
lands between that was sealed away by a
swordsman
it evidently still has influence in that
it was able to somehow curse melania
blade amyla to be born afflicted of rot
so much so that she became known as a
goddess of rot
but the connection doesn't end there the
prosthesis where heirloom tells
melania's story though born into the
accursed rot when the young girl
encountered her mentor and his flowing
blade she gained wings of unparalleled
strength so the blind swordsman and his
flowing blade sealed away the rot and
taught melania how to grow strong
despite or maybe because of its curse
again we don't learn much about the rock
god itself it was sealed and cursed
melania but we don't know its ambitions
or machinations we can see that it finds
something of an adversary in flowing
water the blind swordsman is described
as using a flowing sword and there's
even a weapon called the flowing curved
sword whose description reads legends
speak of a master of the sword garbed in
blue and his curved blade that was
patterned after flowing water whereas
rot is stagnation flowing water is
continual changing and progression the
game even says as much the blue cloth
set likely the clothing of the swordsman
reads the blue color of its fabric
symbolizes brisk waters as fluid and
flowing as the sword in the hand of its
wearer just as still waters turn foul
stagnation leads to decay
whatever more there is to be said of the
rot god may be lost to the flow of time
and a fun fact before we leave this god
melania's weapon the hand of melania has
a unique weapon art called the waterfowl
dance waterfowl like water bird and its
move set is similar to the flowing
curved swords moveset so if the blue
cloth set is the set of her blind
swordmaster there's a nice poetry
between her water fowl dance and the set
talking about still water turning foul
as in bad stagnant or unhealthy i
thought that was a really nice piece of
poetry
last among our explicitly named outer
gods is the god of the death birds only
one item references this being the twin
bird kite shield which reads the twin
bird is said to be the envoy of an outer
god and mother of the death birds
there are plenty of death bird items
that talk about their rite of death and
ashen remains and whatnot but no other
mention or reference to their god
interesting that it's a mother but this
one seems to like death whereas the
previous mother was pretty exclusively
loving blood so probably not the same
being and otherwise crow god is a
mystery finally we fall upon a set of
gods that are not necessarily referred
to as outer gods or even gods but have
some significant presence to be in the
conversation
first is the fel god clearly named by
the incantation flame of the fel god the
fel god is one associated with fire and
the fire giants the incantation says
that it releases a ball of raging fire
said to be inhabited by a fel god it
also says that the fel god still lurks
within the fire giants the giants were
deeply associated with flames and that's
why the order employed the help of the
frozen zamor warriors to combat them the
mountaintop of giants is littered with
their frozen bodies their flame power is
expounded on in the burn of flame
incantation
it reads the fire giants borrowed from
the power of a fell god and still they
were defeated yet their failure released
them from their solitary curse to serve
as keepers of the flame for eternity
we might be able to find the identity of
this fel god if we connect the note
about how the fel god still lurks within
the fire giants to the one-eyed shield
which reads a tricksome shield made from
white stone depicting a malformed
one-eyed god the barrel of a firearm
pokes through the open mouth once
worshipped by the giants this evil deity
is believed to have been slain by queen
america
with this in mind the cutscene from the
fight with the fire giant may reveal the
fel god to be residing within the last
fire giant who we slay perhaps this was
simply an ancient patron god of the
giants after all we see the greater will
favor the people of the order the
frenzied flame has an affinity for the
merchant clan the death bird mother must
like the death birds and we'll see with
the next entry in our list that the
dragons had their own god too
one final note while on the giants the
other item from the fire giant's
remembrance is the giant's red braid
which reads every giant is red of hair
and radagon was said to have despised
his own red locks perhaps that was a
curse of their kind between this and his
son radon's great size it seems likely
that ratagan could have been at least
part giant
moving on i mentioned that the dragons
had their own god another deity
referenced in exactly one item the
remembrance of the dragon lord it reads
the dragonlord whose seat lies at the
heart of the storm beyond time is said
to have been elden lord in the age
before the earth tree once his god was
fled the lord continued to await its
return
there is nothing else that references
this god so it's a god that was around
before the greater will made its move
but fled once the order of the elden
ring began to throw its weight around
the time of the dragons is referenced by
each drake talisman they ruled the
prehistoric era of the erd tree
protecting their lord as a wall of
living rock but we don't learn more
about their god
placidus the dragonlord was waiting for
the god's return but it seemed to never
come another casualty of the
machinations of the greater will but
with so little information about it or
the time of the dragons it's hard to
make any proper judgment
finally we arrive at our last possible
outer god likely the most contentious
one too it is the supposed god of the
moon or darkmoon or full moon or black
moon or moon and stars or just night the
community can't really decide on a name
this is an entity that i think exists in
some way may be like the primeval
current of the mages but i'll be upfront
that i do not think it is an outer god
this supposed god of the moon would be
involved in the age of stars ending the
end of ronnie's quest the connections of
ronnie's line and the moon are clear to
be fair both her and her mother have
moon spells which discuss their
experience with the moon entity ronald
encountered the enchanting full moon
when she was young and later it would
bewitch the academy a young ronnie
encountered the dark moon left by the
hand of her mother and beheld something
cold dark and veiled in a cult mystery
rey lucaria is referenced as the house
of the full moon ronnie is referred to
as lunar princess ronnie in the darkmoon
ring but even with all of this the moon
is never described with the agency or
identity of the other outer gods
both the greater will and the frenzied
flame have motives and take specific
action or try to have you take such
action to achieve certain ends the
formless mother is explicitly called an
outer god and stated to have desires for
wounds the god of scarlet rot does not
have much opportunity for desire or
action but it is explicitly called an
outer god and we see its impact in the
lake of rot and in melania the death
word god is explicitly referred to as is
the dragon god and the fel god the first
as an outer god the latter two as
deities worshiped in their own right
but none of this is true of the moon
whichever version you choose it is never
referred to as really doing anything or
exhibiting certain desires or simply
having an identity
yeah it was enchantingly encountered by
ranala and bewitched the academy but
these words work just as well for an
alluring natural wonder or source of
power or insight similar to the primeval
current that various mages peered into
and developed spells in inspiration of
the moon and its themes and connection
with ronnie and the age of stars ending
is worthy of its own video but from what
i've presented here and from everything
that i've seen it seems clear to me that
it is not an outer god if it is it is of
a different kind to every other outer
god that we know of and at that point
calling it the same kind of thing and
outer god doesn't really make much sense
to me
the outer gods are interfering beasts
perhaps we have them to thank for the
existence of life in the lands between
but their meddling has also brought
domination and disarray some of the most
sympathetic characters at least to me
like ronnie and mikala are dedicated to
warding off their influence and living
freely outside their control living so
that they and we can enact our own will
not subject to some greater will
in light of that i like the concepts of
these gods and think they present a nice
backdrop for our tarnished to struggle
through the world and against demigods
gods and that thing even beyond god's
outer gods
in this game in this struggle we can
find and maybe even make our own path
if you want to learn more about each of
these outer gods then i would recommend
subscribing i plan to talk about not
only the moon and ronnie but more of
these gods as we piece together more
information on each one
and especially if any dlc brings new
info with that i hope you enjoyed the
video and that i will see you in the
next one thanks for watching bye
you